[Musique]
samedi à split single
station originaire c'est ken follett
vous l'aurez reconnu qu'ils nous
expliquent qu'il déplie littéralement
l'oeuvre d'art que la tapisserie de
bayeux
c'est un dépliant qu'il avec lui et si
cette tapisserie qui a mis là dans le
fond qui lui a inspiré son plus récent
roman leur et le crépuscule et l'eau
parce que ces détails bien la vie
quotidienne des gens et c'est un roman
qui se déroule avant sa très populaire
saga les piliers de la terre
on remonte à l'an mil mais le romancier
ken follett d'un cumul 36 ouvrage 176
millions de copies vendues dans le monde
mais je lui ai parlé il ya quelques
jours bonsoir qu'une toilette et
bienvenue à 24,67 un plaisir de vous
parler
à l'occasion de la publication de votre
récente ouvrage le crépuscule et loeb
est ce que vous pouvez au bo vient de
voir un court extrait de votre
présentation de la tapisserie de bayeux
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à écrire
cette histoire et qu'est ce qui vous a
inspiré
bon j'ai voulu faire quelque chose un
attendu parce que j'ai écrit à les
piliers de la terre et puis un roman qui
prend pas ce sont cinquante ans après ça
et puis une troisième 3ème cent
cinquante ans après ça et en ont va on a
prévu que je vais me répéter mais comme
artiste il faut le pas faire ce que on
attend donc j'ai décidé de faire un
préquel
et en plus cette époque environ l'an mil
c'est un tournant dans l'histoire de
l'europe parce que c'est le fin des as
de l'âge des ténèbres et le commencement
b2 du moyen-âge et le renaissance de de
la culture européenne
mm et j'aime beaucoup les tournants dans
dans un roman et et c'est extrêmement
intéressant que vous y soyez est inspiré
de cette tapisserie de
mieux pour la vie quotidienne des gens
pour documenter votre recherche
oui le tapis est formidable parce que ça
vous montre des choses de chaque jour
quotidienne
par exemple on voit les gens qui
déjeunent
on peut voir leurs plats on voit les
gens qui construit les bateaux on voit
les gens avec leur chien blé les
vêtements les outils les choses tout à
fait normal ces détails sont un peu
difficiles à trouver pour l'acheter les
bras parce que c'était ténébreux est ce
que on a beaucoup évolué depuis ce
moyennant h
en termes de cruauté et d'inhumanité des
tickets ce qu'on a à k quand on pense à
l'époque que l'on vit actuellement
oui c'est les lâches ténébreux était
très brutale et le progrès était un peu
lente après mais là je ténébreux on
était toujours fois en avait on avait
toujours faim c'était en vie violente a
pas de médecin qu'on pourra pour faire
pour soigner
c'était une vie terrible mais pour mais
à mon avis les gens étaient même que
nous similaire que nous à leurs soucis
sont l'amour ma le mariage
des enfants l'argent l'emploi la guerre
violence et si vous étiez si on écrit
une histoire qu'il s'agit de ces choses
fondamentales le lecteur dans le 21e
siècle peut tout à fait comprendre la
vie de quelqu'un du de la xième siècle
il y en a qui au fil des pages me disent
y voir un parallèle avec la situation
actuelle qui se passe aux etats unis qu
on peut y lire s'appuie voir
on peut y voir et déceler des éléments
de d'injustice ou d'abus que l'on peut
voir aux états unis avec le président
mais quand on quand on regarde ce que il
manquerait dans le xième siècle on voit
comment notre vie sera si nous faisons
les changes que on demande dans la
maison blanche et même se passe c'est
pas seulement aux états unis vous voyez
dans en pologne par exemple où le
gouvernement veut bien contrôlé les
juges en hongrie par exemple
évidement russe nous nous voyons que le
ce que nous appelons la règle du loi et
n'est pas aujourd'hui n'est pas
automatique mais vous avez des
présidents le premier ministre
aujourd'hui qui ne le veut pas qui veut
contrôler les juges et ça c'est à mon
avis c'est très dangereux et dont le
crépuscule et l'eau
nous voyons des gens en qui demandent
justice
et il ne le trouve pas on vous dit de
taboulé de toute façon que cette quête
de liberté de justice
elle est toujours à refaire et c'est
rien de réglé sans nous dire comment se
termine le crépuscule les lots est ce
que la justice finit par triompher
je ne peux pas dire normand leur ont
fini et les lecteurs savent que en
général je préfère les fin mai de le le
progrès mach est très longtemps la règle
du loi chaath a demandé des siècles de
deux batailles politiques mais nous
voyons aujourd'hui comment il est
fragile vous avez déclaré
quant à 30 c'est terrible c'est les
américains le release
on va aller vers les années sombres et
votre livre parle quand même de chaos
avez vous des craintes c'est pas le
chaos que donges et j'ai peur c'est
c'est le néofascisme céline les
gouvernements que que ne veulent pas
d'une démocratie liberté justice c'est
l'ailé les présidents les prix première
mi- premier ministre autoritaire et un
nationaliste populiste et
malheureusement les gens qui les aiment
qu'ils disent chaque fois que le
président adjoint dit quelque chose au
sujet des terribles à mexicali tout ça
il y a des gens qui dès hier
et enfin enfin c'est la faute du peuple
qui crierait un ken follett de l'an 3000
une question complètement folle qui
écrivait
l'un écrit un cas une fois l'aide de
l'an 3000 sur les années 2000 milles à
plus tard hahaha
mais jamais je ne sais pas parce que on
ne sait pas comment ça va finir
et un roman doit à un roman a besoin
d'un résolution la vie vraie des fois
vous n'avez pas de résolution vous
n'avez pas un fin mai dans un roman dans
la littérature
il faut que que ça finit avec quelque
chose qui satisfait fille assez et je
dois faire mes lecteurs et il me lisent
ils me lisent pour claire mais c'est un
fait vous avez votre réputation mais
c'est pour vous devez vous avez vendu
près de 175 millions de livres depuis
que vous avez laissé le journalisme que
vous n'aimiez pas pour devenir écrivain
est ce que qu'est ce que l'histoire nous
apprend au fond on dit que l'histoire ne
se répète mais il y a des échos est ce
qu'on apprend c'est comment comment les
les changements arrivent et commander
fois le progrès et qu'elle allait
reverser nous faisons le progrès par par
deux maîtres en avance 1 1 me soit en
arrière voilà par exemple dans les
années 60 on a fait des choses des
choses merveille par exemple en
angleterre des lois qui disent que les
on peut pas payer les femmes moins que
les hommes pour la même travail l'homme
le travail on a dû faire une loi que ce
n'est pas un crime d'être guèye a
beaucoup de lois et puis en 1968 on a
tué martin luther king en nature et
bobby cole ld et puis nous avons pour le
président richard nixon
j'ai dit bon c'est terminé ça alors là
on n'a pas du tout mais c'était pas vrai
on n'a pas du tout on a perdu un pote
mais en angleterre
aujourd'hui je n'essaie pas un crime
d'être gay on va avoir un game mariage
c'est g contre le loir le traiter les
femmes différents que les hommes dans le
lobe l'emploi dans leur dans le chantier
notre progrès n'était pas annulée en
terminant m
c'est la pandémie chez vous comme si
nous le monde est paralysé le monde est
inquiet quelle réflexion cela vous
inspire-t-il d'un terminal comme vous
l'avez vécu mon jour de travail n'a pas
changé je m'asseyais ici où je suis
aujourd'hui j'écris toute la journée
j'ai des enfants et des petits enfants
qui habitent aux états unis et je ne
peux pas les voir
c'est peut-être possible d'y aller mais
quand j'arrive
est-ce que je vais donner aux petits
enfants bleu verront cela comme nadine
19 donc c'est trop dangereux je ne veux
pas la fermer mais
ça me manque et la quarantaine vous êtes
déjà écrire votre prochain ouvrage j'ai
j'ai commencé un nouveau roman
il y a il y a un an mais je ne veux pas
en parler parce que ça va peut-être
changer alors qu'il fallait en terminant
je vais vous faire un reproche
le livre est très lourd et les gens le
soir n'ose pas le déposer pour se
reposer un peu et continuer à tourner
les pages
j'espère bien je sers bien c'est parce
que c'est chaque je veux penser qu' il
n'y a jamais une page où on peut dire ah
le bon moment pour aller dormir au 10
mai jusqu'aux fins très bien écouter
merci beaucoup et qu'elle ferait d'avoir
pris le temps de parler aujourd'hui de
ce nouveau roman le crépuscule et l'aube
chez robert laffont en français et au
plaisir de vous reparler chez moi je
vous remercie
merci à vous revoir au revoir